gee brain what are we going to watch
tonight the worst thing you can imagine
pinky 37 percent on Rotten Tomatoes
Fantastic Four rise of the Silver Surfer
37 37 in a row I haven't seen this one
up big shock we love the first one so
much this is the the Commish universe
yeah the miche's the thing yeah okay do
you know we think about Silver Surfer I
don't know a thing I have never read a
Fantastic Four comic or a Silver Surfer
comic so I had no idea what the story is
or anything
not much I always was like you know
spider-man hmm like that was my thing
Batman was my thing so like Silver
Surfer the first spider-man he's with
the Fantastic Four is the first official
yes actually that's true yeah he tries
to he basically shows up he's like give
it a job bitch and that's actually the
only time at that interest in the
Fantastic Four I'm just like Oh
spider-man want to be allocate its
interests remember some nonsensical
thing like well we're kind of a
nonprofit organization like we don't
really pay P it was like we got it
get your money somewhere I don't know
it's been so long since I read that
again for our sins this is fantastic for
to rise of the Silver Surfer back when
their logo was only a half a minute
yes they're three minutes even that
title almost was like ashamed to show
but it was here's a four rises and said
oh whatever just watch it we were get
your money so it's cool
ah that's Mars well this is a huge Japan
what I like how they have to tell us
it's Japan as if really you couldn't
tell by the Japanese people the fishing
boat the Japanese flag on the fishing
boat and Mount Fuji in the background
that's not Jessica Alba and that little
girl is not Krista heavens
which one did you pick
with them little flowers he kind of
sounds like dr. girlfriend oh come on ma
knock Captain America
you're such a little shit in this movie
did the Fantastic Four have a plane they
have all sorts of shit
this is stupid they had a fucking office
building with a giant bore on it okay no
that's a fake name no directors names
Tim's stories I'm Frank acting do you
think that's like an Alan Smithee name I
don't care there's so much more dumb to
focus on I'm here on this porno party so
does everything stretch and as I know
your porn name what's your real name
why do these movies think we don't want
to see these people kick some ass and
fight crime
I do a dumb stretchy dance move come on
oh yeah you got this face going there
you go this talks on the prank unless
you need to do jello shots off
somebody's stomach that's a great idea
hey kid no no I'm like seven down I'm
good see we just wrote two better I
don't like the idea of sharing sensitive
information with the civilian scientists
but this movie's gonna be a disaster
we're shutting it down for national
security reasons as you may know they've
been we see yeah as you know that's like
the most famous bad line you know movies
doomed when has that line also that's a
carry-on oh my a minute there's the way
he says anomalies or what could go wrong
or my all-time favorite we've got this
like that one just can die all right
mark here we go again
we're back yeah but that's another one
you see I'm getting married this
Saturday I just don't have the time why
don't you get married next Saturday it's
a special day and he just danced with
two hookers we're in love hookers they
were stripper it's gonna Brian no hooker
his name candy that's a stripper name
you are surprisingly informed on this
subject matter it's just common sense
I know to make that sound it kind of
flapped around like it was plastic or
something we're making that thing for
the general are you yes Susy doesn't
know anything about it don't worry you
know he sounds like remember the ben
affleck batman voice it sounds like him
drunk I don't think you should be
driving the car
eyes are fine after a few bad titties ah
this is why Robin is dead this is like
some sort of bizarro universe Captain
America like this is the evil twin
captain no this is the bizarro
Incredibles doing everything wrong being
credits Robert De Niro's Frankenstein
yeah you may be wondering why a
woodchuck is officiating the ceremony I
can't believe you brought a crashing
helicopter to our bed you would so do
that oh no there's Tom Green a room
talking in the background that would
have been amazing getting them a wedding
without it turning into World War 3
you're right can we deal with World War
3 your sister's on fire flying through
the air just watch first-timers movie
had some decent camera issues look funny
they do why does this always happen to
me
well we can take some guesses it's the
hall fanservice and lazy screenwriting
honey
unlucky bride-to-be Sue Storm turned
invisible
and it seems she's saying that way after
yesterday's embarrassing fiasco find
something oh my god this is like life
with the Kardashians and the two of us
will live our lives and raise a family
like normal people and we won't go
around saving people we don't do that
anyway you're right
we'll do less of it I don't believe any
of this Von Doom you took just from a
marketing standpoint you call
company doom is that just bad PR guys
we've got a serious problem
I read the rest of the script this is
the first act which are a sexist camp in
the second act the third act we get no
more sequels we found our first big plot
all and all right guys ha ha ha there's
something funny about the cars are still
driving like a ferris wheel is falling
over all the waters J sister people yeah
the British Way move on the lip we don't
agree to this this whole performance can
be summed up with it if I knew that I
wouldn't need you people would feel my
cleavage behind your forehead but your
head literally melt into my cleavage
were you just waiting outside the
bathroom to try and catch me in a towel
I can't believe you're gonna have a
career after this I'm engaged to the
hottest girl on the planet
Oh also great at yeah that's cool that's
cool
I'm a scientist as well but hottest girl
on the planet all right I'll take your
sloppy seconds here be really cool or
really dull
let's see what choice you make movie
you chose really dumb okay now we can
write that down like fucking father bear
there's always a choice not always the
spoon is not a spoon I'm I am the Silver
Slipper I want to be there for the
questioning that's not gonna happen
please make sure our guests remain here
why they have superpowers too they
figured all this stuff there is no
reason for them not to be there can I
just remind you that we could blow all
of you all the kingdom comes
wait he protected me from the missile
why would he do that
maybe he thinks you're cute well I am
the hottest girl in the universe as you
all have said why did you try to protect
me I think the hottest girl in the
planet I can't believe we can trust this
is the second time we can't trust doom
he needs to do that ones just you know
I've never been the giving type read the
words first rugby - that would be cool
you look cool enough soon every day the
mask on that voice command that'd be
perfect
Oh No they're going to kill her off
listen we need to get married right now
I could whale on him if I could get
close enough that he could see me coming
from a mile away
I just closed my eyes and imagined
drunken Batman you're right
Alfred there's something it's clobbering
time
Doctor Doom just go
[Laughter]
even that hit dope gels is like one of
the few people were you just looking at
his body and you know who it is his
fucking hand is just got so many muscles
in and everything
I will interpretive dance you to death
we can't run away from our
responsibilities and the people we need
to protect why it's all you've been
doing through these films if it wasn't
for the team the whole world would be
gone by now
what about having a normal life a family
who says you have to be normal to have a
family they're really trying to hammer
away their importance Venice is sinking
into the sea but we can waste a few
extra seconds oh my god
pretty bad but honestly probably better
than the first did that shorter it felt
a lot shorter what was it yeah just our
thirty
it's just forget about me you say you've
seen this movie before and you totally
forgot I did yeah okay I didn't see it
from the beginning but somewhere at the
halfway point right around London I'm
like it's like Hunt for Red October
I know dish film you know conclusions
were all wrong
yeah that's not much else so that
happened that's about it I'm gonna tell
him to keep the weed whacking down I
just buy more Jesse in this movie and
giggle is that true
you